welcome back ta and joh you're still
hanging with us ta's new movie is called
next goal win so in honor of that it's
time for a game we hilariously called
Next roll
wins next
[Music]
roll but we always cap it off with a
fantastic singer so thank you Jesse John
has kindly agreed to host John I now
give you control of the show absolutely
thank you Kelly what a wonderful title
what you what we are clever such a
clever group of writers wouldn't you say
yes you're welcome all right in in this
game the answers are all actors or
actresses who have won Oscars but the
clues will be about the roles that they
had just before they won those Awards
okay if you know the answer you hit your
button and you say it if you're wrong
the other person will get an opportunity
to steal okay okay oh ready I just want
everyone to know I don't know things
like this I don't either I'm stressed
out I don't watch other people's
work I only like my own stuff and that's
great and that's why I made it entertain
myself oh my God I love it on Sunday I
just watch my
boxit with with com can't wait to beat
you and now that makes me happy I'm also
fiercely fiercely competitive and I hate
losing and If I Lose I'm going to if we
don't start if we don't start the game
Rock and I'm tring this place sorry
we're running out of time let go we had
the pre notices here we go first
question disclaimer before her third
Oscar win she was seen alongside Steve
Martin in its
complicated M
[Applause]
Street that's my favorite I'm sorry we
needed that in the form of a
question what oh I was like you got it
question Assurance all right are you
ready good
luck all right here we go
question number two he played a high
school football coach in Remember the
Titans before Denzel
Washington what is
happening
oh oh my
gosh getting
embarrassed I love Denzel here we go
continuing on question number three she
played a safe cracker and daughter of
Donald southernland in The Italian Job
before winning the Charlie best actress
for Monsters Charlie yes yes yes yes
they're wrong I said it wrong you know
what I apologize cuz I feel like I said
her name wrong too sorry that's three
for Kelly I'm kind of kicking your ass a
chance all right here we go you weren't
kidding about being bad at
this I really wasn't I'm an honest
person all right here we go she was a
Runaway Bride just before she a
something
gosh Julia Roberts I am incredible
before she was a in brovich she answers
Julia Roberts you get it You' think I'd
take it easy on you and be a good host
but I number five we're getting down
she's almost boxing you out here hold on
a second God I feel power question
number five before winning the Oscar for
his role in Forest Gump he won for his
well we don't know his his role in
Philadelphia Tom
Han
is that game over let's just end the
game you know give me one this man got
on stage looking all right all right all
right oh Matthew mcne all right let
[Applause]
me called Matthew MCC 62 nothing beol
here's the thing we started off that we
both knew the
answer both but I'm quicker but I'm
quick like at the beginning there's just
none she's got a r she's got a ranch in
Montana that's what she does I'm going
for it I'm going for it all right number
seven oh that is time for our last
question boy you were trending
too it's not about the amount of answers
about the quality of the
answ not quantity here is our final
question we heard the buzzer there how
much is this one worth uh we should
probably for champion of the we probably
should say this is worth uh seven points
okay so you have
a we should say that and and riding
along with this the winning prize is the
passenger seat to a 91 Toyota
Celica I Poss all right here we go last
question this actor had some desperate
hours before eating a liver with some
FAA beans and a nice kante you were in
their first Anthony Hopkins damn it
Anthony
Hopkins
all right fine um thank you for hosting
John everybody watch the national dog
show Thanksgiving Day on MBC and be sure
to check out ta's film next goal win
it's some theaters right now we will be
right
[Music]
back
[Applause]
thank you guys y'all have a great night
I'm going
home